quand sur les chaînes parlementaires
pourtant à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre ce matin sur
notre antenne à les travaux de la
mission d'information du sénat sur le
médiator
les sénateurs entendent ce matin
philippe bas ancien ministre de la santé
du gouvernement villepin et actuel
président de l' agence nationale chargée
de la sécurité sanitaire de
l'alimentation de l'environnement et du
travail
les sénateurs doivent prochainement
remettre leur rapport sur l'évaluation
et le contrôle du médicament
xavier bertrand ministre de la santé
après avoir reçu le rapport debré a
indiqué qu'il attendait beaucoup des
travaux des missions parlementaires
notamment en ce qui concerne le rôle de
l'afssaps tout de suite donc les
auditions médiator bonne matinée à tous
nous accueillons aujourd'hui donc
monsieur philippe bas qui est président
de l'association nationale de sécurité
sanitaire de l'alimentation de
l'environnement et du travail
qu'est ce que j'ai dit à sociale ah oui
ça n'a rien à voir
excusez moi je sais pas ce qui m'arrive
bien sûr qui saisit de l'agencé parce
qu'un vous agissez bien entendu donc
vous êtes le président de conseil
d'administration
oui mais enfin bon j'espère que vous
agissez quand même alors il ya donc
président de l'andp cesse et j'ajoute
pour ceux qui ne s'en souviendraient pas
que vous êtes ancien mise de la santé et
des solidarités en 2007 et ancien
directeur de cabinet du ministre du
travail des affaires sociales de 95 à 97
alors je vous rappelle que cette
audition est donc public et qu'elle est
ouverte à la presse et que fait l'objet
d'un enregistrement audiovisuel en vue
de son éventuelle diffusion sur en fin
de sa diffusion d'ailleurs sur le site
internet bus
du sénat et son éventuelle diffusion sur
public sénat pour la forme je vous
demanderais puisque cette audition
république vous le savez lire
l'application de l'article l 4113 tirs
et 13 du code de la santé publique de
nous faire connaître si vous en avez vos
liens avec des entreprises produisant ou
exploitants des produits de santé des
organismes de conseil intervenant sur
ces produits sont monsieur nice vous
avez la parole monsieur le président je
n'ai aucun lien avec aucune entreprise
et a fortiori aucune entreprise du monde
de la santé
merci maintenant comment voulez-vous
nous procédions est ce que vous voulez
faire une intervention liminaire de
quelques minutes où est ce que vous
allez visage monsieur le président j'ai
eu lieu il y en a il y en a pas qu'en
j'offre cette possibilité généralement
la personnalité aletti à qui je
m'adresse utilisent cette possibilité de
de faire une intervention liminaire bien
je vous en remercie monsieur le
président voilà vous avez rappelé à
l'instant certaines des fonctions que
j'ai exercé jeu j'ai été impliqué dans
les questions de santé publique depuis
en réalité assez longtemps puisque j'ai
été directeur adjoint du cabinet de
simone veil entre 93 et 95 puis
directeur du cabinet de jacques barrot
quand il était aux affaires sociales et
à la ce et à la santé en réalité est au
travail et à l'emploi
et de fait j'ai été en charge de la
sécurité sociale et du médico social
pendant deux ans et quelques semaines
comme vous l'avez rappelé ministre de la
santé et des solidarités
en 2007 je dois vous dire immédiatement
que je n'ai jamais participé
en quoi que ce soit à la gestion de ce
dossier du médiator
j'appelle ça le jeu s'arrête c'est ainsi
d'ailleurs un médicament qui a qui a
évolué dans la solitude complète cette
main de l'oublier c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs le premier ni le dernier je
pense à c'est peut-être l'une des
raisons est
deuxième accident ça c'est
extraordinaire le néanmoins ayant connu
ces matières dans leur généralité
peut-être en effet pourrais je vous dire
quelques mots sur mes réactions à cette
à cette affaire ce que je voudrais
d'abord dire et pardon si je le dit
trivialement c'est qu'il faut prendre
garde à ne pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau
du bain
je me souviens justement en 1993 la
création de l' agence du médicament et
je me souviens à l'époque ce qu'était la
direction de la pharmacie du ministère
de la santé de même que je me souviens
aussi à la même époque où s'est créé l'
agence française du sang quelle était la
situation de la gestion de la
transfusion sanguine et des médicaments
durée dérivés du sang à cette époque je
dois dire aujourd'hui avec le recul que
le système que nous avons mis en place à
partir de 1993 et qui n'a jamais cessé
d'être confortée au fil des années par
tous les gouvernements quelle que soit
la majorité sur laquelle ils se sont
appuyés et dans l'ensemble de mon point
de vue et malgré le drame que nous
venons de constater avec cette affaire
du médiator
un système qui a représenté un progrès
très importants en termes de sécurité
sanitaire et une de mes mises en garde
si je peux me permettre d'en formuler
c'est de ne pas tout mettre par terre
aujourd'hui alors qu'on remet en place
le système pour évaluer les facteurs de
faiblesse qui l'a révélé dans cette
tragique affaire du médiateur nos
agences d'ailleurs honte en europe une
réputation
très forte et served agence de référence
pour bien des aspects de la gestion de
la sécurité sanitaire et je tenais à le
souligner est de mon point de vue dans
cette affaire du médiator
l' agence des produits de santé a
naturellement sa part de responsabilité
mais je crois que on a tort de focaliser
l'essentiel de la responsabilité sur
elle et je vais essayer de d'expliquer
ce point de vue si vous me le permettez
bien sûr bien sûr le travail
d'évaluation surtout pour les
médicaments qui font l'objet d'une
autorisation de mise sur le marché
parfois anciennes est un travail qui
doit aujourd'hui faire l'objet de
d'amélioration car il n'a pas permis de
retenir entre les mailles du filet ce
médicament dont on sait que des alertes
à ses nombreuses ont pu être données au
fil des années et c'est ce que a
posteriori j'ai découvert comme chacun
d'entre nous et là il y a donc une
défaillance des mécanismes de
l'évaluation de médicaments déjà sur le
marché
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que si
l'on veut corriger dans de bonnes
conditions ses défaillances
il faut le faire sans esprit de système
et avec pragmatisme
nous avons une difficulté aujourd'hui
c'est celle de l' expertise mais à trop
vouloir faire reposer exclusivement une
réforme sur l'indépendance de
l'expertisé on passera à côté de
beaucoup de problèmes et je crois que
autant il faut renforcer cette
indépendance qui d'ailleurs des 93 a été
fortement renforcée avec les
déclarations d'intérêts d'abord secrète
puis public autant cette indépendance a
encore été renforcée par les systèmes
d'appel à candidatures pour éviter la
cooptation et lens reçoit celui est
maintenant complètement évitèrent au
temps au temps des progrès ont été
accomplis dans ce domaine sur autant il
faut continuer à rechercher
l'application de règles déontologiques
forte mais il n'est pas
cible de trouver des experts qui n'est
strictement aucune expérience de la
production industrielle de médicaments
et de l'évaluation des médicaments à
travers le travail qu'ils ont pu faire
avec l'industrie c'est ma conviction
j'entends bien qu'elle ait discuté mais
je crois que ce sera beaucoup plus
féconds après avoir renforcé encore
toutes les règles éthiques que nous
avons à appliquer dans le domaine de l'
expertise de faire en sorte que la
procédure d'évaluation avec les experts
soient le plus contradictoire le plus
transparente possible plutôt que de
vouloir à priori par un excès de
puritanisme faire en sorte que les
experts ne n'ai jamais eu le moindre
contact avec l'industrie ce qui est
d'ailleurs tout à fait en sens inverse
de tout ce que l'on recherche dans la
progression de la recherche appliquée
dans notre pays on peut pas à la fois du
côté des universités vouloir se
rapprocher de l'industrie et du côté de
l' expertise en matière de sécurité
sanitaire vouloir en être totalement aux
antipodes mais si vous me permettez
monsieur le ministre en l'occurrence en
ce qui concerne le médiator ça n'est pas
c'est une défaillance effectivement de
l'afssaps bien entendu mais il ya aussi
une défaillance du politique
parce que à deux reprises en 99 et en
2006 et experts ont fait leur travail
en tout cas les experts de la commission
de la transparence en indiquant que ce
médicament ne présentait aucun intérêt
et qu'il ne devait pas être prise en
charge par l'assurance maladie
or qu'est-ce qui s'est passé eh bien on
n'a pas tenu compte de l'avis de ses
experts et le ministre mattei qui a été
auditionné il ya quelques semaines a
bien indiqué que
une fois qu'un médicament était mis sur
le marché même si on découvrait après
coup qu'il a fait qu'il avait 10 au un
service médical qu'il présentait un
service médical insuffisant
il était politiquement très très
difficile de le retirer
donc il est préférable me semble-t-il
d'agir en amont plus qu'autre plutôt que
d'essayer d'agir et l'expérience
démontre qu'on ne peut pas une fois que
le médicament et sur le marché donc il
ya là un véritable problème qui pose non
seulement la dépose des expertises mais
aussi la capacité du politique à prendre
des décisions ou plutôt son incapacité à
prendre les décisions qui correspondrait
à l'intérêt des patients alors là c'est
c'est sur ce problème là je crois qu'il
faut essayer de réfléchir pour éviter
que demain se reproduisent le même
phénomène
monsieur présidents vivent n'est qu'à
robidas
nous sommes exactement dans la même
direction ce que j'essaye de vous dire
dans un premier temps c'est qu'on peut
pas faire porter tout le poids de la
responsabilité sur le seul processus de
décision au moment de l'autorisation sur
de la mise sur le marché et je crois que
vous avez raison de souligner qu'il y a
ensuite beaucoup de carrefour pour
lesquels des signalements sont faits et
dont on n'a pas tiré toutes les
conséquences alors je minorerait si vous
le permettez un peu ce que vous disiez
je ne crois pas que ce soit seulement le
politique qui soit défaillant en réalité
quand qui invite cicely alors alors qui
est défaillant personnes
si vous aussi vous me permettait de
terminer ce que j'ai commencé je vous
donnerai mon point de vue si c'est vous
et que vous voulez recruter mois est ce
que ce que ce que je remarque vous citez
l'évaluation de la transparence la
transparence
d'après ce que j'ai lu postérieurement
la transparence ne dit pas ce médicament
est un poison
elles disent que le service médical
rendu ne justifie pas la prise en charge
qui medica absolue ce n'est pas la même
chose donc un signalement sur le danger
d'un médicament et à ce moment là la
décision qui est à prendre est une
décision réalité non pas de sécurité
sanitaire mais une décision de gestion
de la sécurité sociale en se disant
qu'il faut que chaque euro dépensé soit
réellement utile à la santé si un
médicament n'apporte pas d'amélioration
du service médical rendu
il est normal de cesser son
remboursement et c'est sur ce point que
je vous rejoins mais là ça n'est pas une
question de sécurité sanitaire
c'est sympa serai moi même si vous
permettez je suis une petite dix ans une
petite comme un petit bémol quoi est ce
que vous êtes et d'indiquer c'est que
malgré tout la commission et non par de
la transparence lorsqu'elle prend ses
avis prend en compte un les effets
indésirables du médicament j'en veux
pour preuve la communication qui a été
faite aux membres de cette mission avant
la réunion de cette commission qui a
pris cet avis sur le mediator la
communication d'une note concernant la
les effets indésirables et la toxicité
du médicament à cette noble d'ailleurs
elle a été publiée effectivement par le
canard enchaîné mais elle existe à elle
existe et nous l'avons pu nous la
procurer
et c'est vrai que ces considérations ne
sont pas étrangères disons aux décisions
ou aux avis que peut émettre la
commission de la transparence parce
qu'il s'agit toujours d'un rapport
commandé à le bénéfice risque donc si la
commission de transparence a estimé
qu'elles ne devaient pas que là c'est
que l'assurance maladie ne devait pas
prendre ce médicament s'est pas
seulement parce qu'ils étaient efficaces
mais parce qu'en plus ils présentaient
des effets indésirables
qui n'était pas acceptable dans la
mesure où ce médicament n'était pas
efficace
je crois que il faut quand même c'est
aussi simple celle aussi c'est dur grâce
t'y connaitre les deux c'est à dire les
effets indésirables et le service
médical rendu est là dans les
médicaments il y a des effets
indésirables absolue mais effets
indésirables n'est pas synonyme de
toxicité ou alors on peut reconnaître à
tout médicament un pouvoir toxiques et
hymne au sulfure ma il ne suffit pas
qu'il y ait un effet indésirable pour
qu'il y ait un risque en termes de
sécurité sanitaire garder le paracétamol
y est toxique
si vous en prenez trop tout et merci
monsieur le président tout est toxique
oui mais pourtant engageant la
pharmacopée beaucoup de médicaments qui
peuvent avoir des effets indésirables et
d'ailleurs à peu près tous c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui caractérise un
médicament par rapport à une poudre de
perlimpinpin alors monsieur le président
moi ce que je veux dire à ce stade
puisque vous avez eu la gentillesse de
me proposer de présenter quelques idées
et quelques pistes de réflexion c'est
que je crois profondément que oui il
faut améliorer la qualité du processus
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché
précédée d'une évaluation pour que les
mailles du filet sont aussi serré que
possible mais j'ajoute qu'il me semble
que quand on fait quand on a fait ce
travail on n'a fait qu'une partie du
travail est peut-être une petite partie
du travail car le danger qui est révélé
par cette affaire du médiator c'est
aussi celui qui vient de la faiblesse de
l'organisation de notre vigilance
pharmaceutique et jean vient exactement
au point qui vous préoccupe
il me semble que dans notre système
c'est la qualité du recueil des
informations des signalements et de leur
exploitation qui a été la plus fortement
défaillante et je crois que c'est sur
ces points qu'il faut s'appliquer le
plus à essayer de faire progresser notre
système tout en confortant ont lieu de
la déstabiliser notre agence
des produits de santé il me semble qu'en
matière de vigilance
le rôle particulier de l'assurance
maladie n'est pas suffisamment exploité
j'en veux pour preuve que depuis 1993 et
la convention des médecins où on parle
de codage des actes et des pathologies
aujourd'hui en 2011 il n'y a toujours
pas ouais à système permettant de
recueillir des informations sur le lien
entre la prescription et la pathologie
diagnostiqués par leur médecin et qu'il
n'ya donc pas d'exploitation de ce
rapport entre diagnostic et
prescriptions au niveau national or
quand vous avez un médicament nous
prenons aujourd'hui l'exemple du
médiator il peut y en avoir d'autres et
même sans doute beaucoup d'autres quand
vous prenez un médicament il est
généralement produit dans le cadre des
indications de son autorisation de mise
sur le marché mais il peut aussi être
prescrit en dehors de ses indications
il se trouve qu'avec le médiator même
les indications de la mm étaient de
mauvaise indication puisque le produit
est toxique
mais dans bien des cas un produit pourra
être tout à fait pertinent dans un
traitement dans le cadre de la mm et
devenir éventuellement dangereux en
dehors de ce cadre
dans d'autres cas produits pertinents
dans le cadre de la mm sera aussi
pertinent dans d'autres cadres
mais dans tous les cas il me semble
qu'au moment où on met sur le marché le
médicament qu'on décide de son prix
qu'il ya un débat avec l'industriel sur
le volume qui sera justifiée et donc au
moment où le prix va être calculée en
fonction du volume vendu volume
justifiée par les pathologies qu'il
s'agit de traiter dans le cadre de la mm
eh bien on va se dire tiens ce
médicament on en consommera cent mille
boîtes par an on découvre qu'on en
consomme quatre cent mille on doit se
demander pourquoi sont consommés les
300000 qui s'ajoutent aux premiers 100
milles dans certains cas 7
mise sous surveillance donnera un
résultat très positif pour six temps à
dire mais oui c'est bien de le prescrire
aussi dans ce cas là on a réussi à
administrer la preuve que c'était bon
pour d'autres pathologies que celles qui
sont prévues dans les indications de la
mêmes mais dans d'autres cas on se dira
il y a là une dérive dangereuse quand on
prescrit ce médicament en dehors du
cadre de l'indication prévu par la mm7
éventuellement source de graves dangers
sanitaires si on avait su faire ça dans
la sphère du médiator si notre
organisation sanitaire
incorporer cette exigence eh bien on
aurait aujourd'hui certainement et
éviter beaucoup de victimes
ce que je veux dire ayant parlé de
l'assurance maladie c'est que
l'assurance maladie ne pourra jamais
faire ça
si le corps médical n'est pas fortement
impliqué dans la mise en place de ce
système de surveillance alors pour le
corps médical
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles ça
n'a pas été mis en place ça signifie
quoi
ça signifie qui se met dans la situation
que des confrères vérifie l'adéquation
de sa prescription à son diagnostic ce
qui est au coeur de son métier et
jusqu'à présent le corps médical dans
son ensemble même si le professe une
grande ouverture d'esprit à l'égard de
l'évaluation de la qualité des soins n'a
pas accepté au niveau de l'organisation
conventionnels ce lien entre le la
prescription et le diagnostic par le
codage des feuilles de soins qui est
aussi pour lui une forte contraire lois
existent quant aux et la loi existe sur
temps je suis tout à fait conscient de
ce fait et nous avons toujours achopper
sur les négociations conventionnelles
sur ce poids et je crois qu'il est plus
que temps que nous fassions un pas en
avant pour réaliser la mise en oeuvre de
ces principes message transmis à
monsieur van roekeghem puisque les
négociations vont commencer à négocier
la convention est le dernier point sur
les médecins tout à fait en lien avec
l'assurance maladie et là je dois le
dire
même si ça ne plaira pas à tout le monde
il y a eu dans une affaire comme celle
du médiator des médecins qui se sont
spécialisés dans la prescription de ce
médicament à titre de coupe faim qui ont
vu grandir leur clientèle en la tirant
par la prescription de ce médicament me
gratte j'en ai eu le témoignage par deux
jeunes médecin consciencieux
accomplissant des remplacements et qui
ont dû faire évacuer si j'ose dire une
partie de la clientèle du médecin qui le
remplaçait et qui étaient habitués à
venir se faire prescrire le médiator
vous avez terminé le sionisme et bien je
vais demander un homme le rapporteur de
bien vouloir vous poser eux des
questions qu'elle souhaite monsieur le
président vous avez ce ministre vous
avez rappelé que dans cette affaire du
médiator
vous n'aviez pas vu passer les choses
lorsque vous aviez certain nombre de
responsabilités
ici nous ne sommes pas des juges pour
élaborer la justice de cette affaire du
médiator il y à d'autres instances
donc je me polarise ray plutôt sur des
questions concernant l'évaluation et le
contrôle du médicament quitte à revenir
peut-être sur la question plus précise
du médiator à l'occasion des questions
que je vais vous poser
vous êtes depuis le mois de janvier
président de l' agence nationale de
sécurité sanitaire de l'alimentation de
l'environnement et du travail
compte tenu de cette fonction et de
votre expérience passée au sein du mit
sa la santé quels enseignements
tirez-vous du du fonctionnement d'une
agence sanitaire
quel regard portez-vous sur celui ci et
en particulier sur le regard de l'
agence française de sécurité sanitaire
des produits de santé
finalement quelques fois il nous a été
dit
on a transféré la direction du
médicament en une agence et le résultat
c'était quoi c'était qu'on avait plus de
moyens autrement dit est-ce que si ces
mêmes moyens étaient regroupés au sein
d'une administration centrale est ce
qu'il faudrait nous vous recentralisez
l'ensemble du dispositif
ou est-ce qu'il faudra il faut garder le
dispositif tel qu'il existe actuellement
en le perfectionnant c'est une question
qui se pose aujourd'hui recentralisation
ou non
même le rapporteur je voudrais dire que
ce n'est pas la principale question que
moi je me pose
mais vous non plus certainement moi je
suis assez pragmatique
oui je crois que on peut tout envisager
mais ce qui est important pour moi c'est
le fond c'est-à-dire compétences des
experts indépendance des experts
indépendants ce scientifique de la
décision fondée uniquement sur des
considérations scientifiques
collégialité transparence tout ça c'est
pour la prise de décisions dans le
processus qui va aboutir soit à la mise
sur le marché soit au retrait
cette une partie du système et l'autre
partie c'est la vigilance agences
régionales de santé médecins assurance
maladie tout doit converger pour que
quand un médecin découvre des effets
toxiques d'un médicament l'information
remonte vite et donne lieu à la mise en
branle d'une surveillance de ce
médicament et d'une nouvelle évaluation
si ça paraisse scientifiquement
justifiée donc la question de savoir si
on fait ça dans le giron du ministère ou
dans une agence indépendante n'est pas
pour moi la principale
la principale question ça va être celle
de la qualité de cette organisation et
des personnes qui vont y concourir mais
si vous me demander ma préférence et
vous me l'a demandé je préfère les
agences c'est vrai que dans
l'organisation de notre état à chaque
fois qu'on a constitué une agence pour
lui faire remplir une mission on a eu
deux avantages celui de l'indépendance
est celui des moyens
vous avez tout à fait raison de dire que
rien ne s'opposerait par principe à ce
qu'on donne des moyens à une
administration de l'état et je suis je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
simplement je me borne à constater que
c'est toujours parce qu'on a créé des
agences qu'on a créé les moyens
nécessaires il avait connu la direction
du médicament et que vous avez connu ce
passage finalement pour nous ce qui est
important de savoir qu'est ce qui a
changé selon autrement dit est-ce qu'on
a adopté finalement un mode de pensée
britannique où il faut développer des
agences pour développer des agences
parce que c'est aussi dans tous les
domaines en abandonnant un certain
nombre de deux fonctions finalement
concrètement pour vous qui avez vu le
passager qui ensuite avait été en charge
avec des fonctions ministérielles
qu'est ce qui a fondamentalement changé
et quelles réformes institutionnelles
aujourd'hui préconisez vous dans le
domaine du médicament pour améliorer
aussi le circuit ils fonctionnement de
ces agences je presse je préconise
surtout de ne pas faire de réformes
institutionnelles et je préconise de
conserver un système tel que nous
l'avons mis en place qui a représenté un
progrès très importants pour la sécurité
sanitaire de notre pays qui a consisté à
créer des institutions indépendantes
reconnues partout en europe pour la
qualité de leur travail et qui assure
l'indépendance de l'évaluation des
risques par rapport au pouvoir politique
mais alors monsieur
le ministre qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette de ski écrit notamment le rapport
de l'igas là il écrit je cite de mémoire
que l' agence enfin l'afssaps a est
structurellement et culturellement en
conflit d'intérêts avec l'industrie
pharmaceutique
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
excessif ou est-ce que vous pensez que
ça correspond à la réalité en fonction
de cette réalité n'y at il pas lieu
quand même de temps viager un certain
nombre de réformes puisque si elle n'est
pas suffisamment indépendante de
l'industrie pharmaceutique comme
semblent le dire ce rapport peut-être
faudrait-il envisager des réformes qui
assure cette indépendance qui
aujourd'hui n'existe pas par exemple au
niveau de la publicité au niveau des
votes formelle d'adoption dès 10 heures
consensus des seuils de majorité des
suites à de nos opinions divergentes
je suis d'accord avec toutes les
propositions rappelé par madame hermange
les et pour partie et non c'est tout à
l'heure ce n'est pas un changement
institutionnel
je ne suis pas d'accord avec l'idée de
supprimer les agences je pense que ce
serait une très grave et lourde erreur
et j'ai trouvé très intéressant le
rapport de l'igas mais il ne se réduit
pas à cette appréciation d'ordre
politique qui dépasse d'ailleurs de
beaucoup le mandat des inspecteurs de
l'igas dit notamment
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas qu'il
faille se départir d'un certain
pragmatisme
oui attention aux conflits d'intérêts
faisons tout pour les proscrire ou pour
quand ils existent les rendre publiques
de sorte que on est à la fois une
expertise de qualité une expertise
indépendante et un débat contradictoire
reposant sur le savoir scientifique
avant de prendre les décisions
mais vous pensez que un expert qui a des
liens d'intérêts
que l'entreprise avec l'industrie
pharmaceutique
quel que soit le laboratoire peut
néanmoins siéger dans des commissions
qui sont chargés d'émettre un avis sur
les médicaments pour le compte de la
puissance publique pour le compte de
l'état vous pensez que c'est compatible
il n'y a pas d' expertise possible en
matière de médicaments pour un
pharmacologie sts en chambre il y a
pour le médicament nécessité absolue
d'une connaissance qui s'acquiert par le
travail avec l'industrie comme par le
travail avec les médecins au cours des
essais thérapeutiques l' expertise par
nature dans ce domaine
elle repose là-dessus et donc ça n'est
plus de l'expertisé mon sillage un
travail avec l'industrie
c'est du travail en chambre des lilas
major sans expérience et ça fait baisser
le niveau de sécurité sanitaire a eu
dans le mail on peut très bien imaginer
que ya un temps pour tout c'est à dire
que pendant que quand les experts
travaillent avec l'industrie
pharmaceutique pour acquérir cette
expérience indispensable dont vous
parlez on pourrait très bien imaginer
qu'ils puissent pas dans le même temps
effectuer ce travail d'expérience pour
le compte de l'état et qu'ils ne
puissent le faire qu'une fois qu'ils
n'ont plus de lien et ils ont abandonné
ses liens avec l'entreprise
vous avez le cas du professeur m'a un
âne qui par exemple qui a eu des liens
effectivement avec l'entreprise mais qui
depuis cinq ans on a plu et il me semble
qu'il est quand même mieux à même
aujourd'hui de d'émettre des avis en
toute indépendance
alors qu'il n'a plus depuis cinq ans de
liens avec l'industrie pharmaceutique
alors que quelqu'un qui en a toujours
me sens moins à même d'émettre des avis
indépendants que ce dernier voyous c'est
ça que il
je voudrais il n'ya tout l'assumer ce
présidente vous êtes mais mais mais non
non je ne suis pas d'accord je ne
voudrais pas qu'il n'y ait que des
retraités pour faire de l' expertise car
même si leurs savoirs est très grand ça
n'est pas le savoir le plus récent et
par conséquent je préfère de beaucoup
qu'on mette en place des règles très
strictes
de plus en plus strictes et elles ont
déjà beaucoup progressé
nous permettant de ne pas nous priver du
concours du meilleur expert dans un
domaine donné sous prétexte qu'il a
travaillé l'année dernière avec une
industrie mais on peut très bien ne pas
se priver de ce concours sans pour
autant lui donner le pouvoir d'émettre
un avis pour le compte de l'état mettra
bien la route nationale est de 6 go
surya notez bien entendu et par
conséquent à partir qu'ils sont c'est la
solidarité existe toute prise de
position qui ne serait pas fondée sur un
raisonnement scientifique passant
l'épreuve du dialogue avec des confrères
de même niveau serait naturellement
disqualifié et par conséquent ce qui
m'importe à moi c'est d'avoir les
meilleurs experts partout et de faire en
sorte que leurs paroles d'experts soit
vraiment une parole d'expert je ne suis
pas assuré que quelqu'un qui a gagné
dans sa vie éventuellement des millions
d'euros avec l'industrie pharmaceutique
sous prétexte qu'ils ne travaillent plus
avec elle depuis cinq ans et d'une
neutralité parfaite et d'une
impartialité totale
comme quoi on sait que je l'évité oui il
faut éviter dans ce domaine d'être porté
par excès de puritanisme à des
situations il est l'heure nous n'avons
plus le jeu l'église de meilleur
contrario celui qui qui n'a plus de
liens d'intérêts que depuis quelques
jours seraient plus indépendant que
celui qui n'a plus de liens depuis cinq
ans et vous savez à quoi c'est une
je le supporte les férus de gerard
puisque je ne sais pas quand général de
l'afssaps qui n'a plus de liens depuis
cinq ans et le directeur de la chasse
qui n'a plus de liens depuis deux mois
et demi donc
je fais une différence néanmoins entre
ces deux experts considérant que le
premier a quand même un recul que n'a
pas le second
et c'est pourquoi j'aurais tendance à
accorder plus de neutralité au premier
qu'au second shore c'est le bon sens
tout cas c'est à mon sens et le bon dieu
merci ce que je devrais dire c'est que
de sa touche que je voulais dire il faut
faire très attention de ne pas écarter
systématiquement toute expertise sous
prétexte que l'expert a pu travailler
avec l'industrie pharmaceutique
il faut aussi prévoir de la collégialité
de la transparence de la contradiction
et permettant ainsi d'avoir les
meilleurs avis pour prendre les
meilleures décisions pour la sécurité
sanitaire sans jamais se reposer sur un
avis unique et je suis aussi d'accord
avec ce que disait madame hermange tout
à l'heure sur la nécessité de faire
s'exprimer publiquement les opinions
divergentes des experts mais ne tarit
sont pâles expertise en mettant des
barrières absolue cherchons au contraire
à chaque fois que nous avons doute sur
l'expert a formulé ce doute pour
relativiser sa parole
non pas pour l'écarter et l'a
disqualifié par avance leurs envies des
murs seront finalement vous êtes vous
vous êtes d'accord avec la proposition
du rapport debré even mon avis pas mal
j'ai faim je me trompe peut-être mais
j'ai cru comprendre que vous êtes enfin
si vous l'avez vous l'avez lu sans doute
un il m'a semblé que vous n'étiez pas
tout à fait d'accord je n'ai pas encore
pris connaissance de ce rapport de
brigitte bardot
mais ce qui m'intéressait c'est à dire
des rapports de pharmacologie sts
surtout je vous en prie un gros un
groupe réduit d'experts de haut niveau
bien rémunérés
protégée par un statut en lieu et place
du recours actuel à une multitude
d'experts internes et externes souvent
en conflit d'intérêts c'est une vision
simpliste des choses j'ai essayé de les
montrer il faut il faut faire en sorte
que nous ayons des experts de très haut
niveau c'est ça le premier impératif
le premier impératif c'est pas de dire
que ces experts ont toujours travaillé
avec une blouse blanche pour éviter
toute contamination par les conflits
d'intérêts c'est de faire en sorte que
nous sachions exactement ce qu'ils ont
fait ce qu'ils font et que nous ayons de
toute façon les meilleurs experts ce que
je mets tout en haut
c'est l'excellence de l' expertise j'ai
besoin de l'expertisé la plus grande
parce que je ne veux pas que nous
permettions de laisser passer entre les
mailles du filet des produits dangereux
c'est tout ce que je vois et ensuite la
question du conflit d'intérêts elle est
essentielle mais elle passe après
l'exigence de la plus haute qualité
d'expérience relais de nos je fais le
lien entre les deux bien sûr mais
j'essaye de faire en sorte que nous
conte bignon tous ces impératifs
non pas en faisant des propositions qui
exclurait parfois de très bons experts
alors que nous pourrions mettre des
conditions éthiques pour le recours à
leur expertise intermédiaire une
commission indépendante des contrôles et
de et la méthodologie d'évaluation des
essais cliniques
ça ça me paraît une excellente
proposition oui mais sur madame claisse
vous avez la parole
oui merci le président vous avez utilisé
monsieur le ministre le terme de
contradictoire tout à l'heure et
j'aimerais savoir à quel niveau précis
de la chaîne d'analysé de décision vous
placer le contradictoire et jusqu'où
justement dans ce conflit d'intérêt dans
cette expertise à vox eu à la commission
des lois le contradictoire je l'entends
bien en amont du jugement
mais au moment du jugement il me semble
essentiel que le juge qu'il soit seul ou
collégial soit parfaitement indépendant
et qu'effectivement si conflit
d'intérêts il doit y avoir au moment des
expertises il soit clairement annoncé y
compris aux juges et à la commission le
juge peu m'importe
l'instance qui va décider qui va donner
la mm ou pas qui va valider les
indications ou pas et c'est donc jusqu
où placez-vous le contradictoire et
jusqu où placez-vous la barrière sur le
conflit d'intérêts rendu public ou non
tout conflit d'intérêts doit être rendu
public
ça pour moi c'est un impératif absolu
deuxièmement tout intérêt que nous
qualifierions il faudrait savoir comment
on évalue cette qualification
faure doit conduire à exclure une
expertise n'empêche pas pour autant
d'auditionner le la personnalité
scientifique qui à ce conflit et
d'intérêts fort ce qui permet de situer
son intervention un autre à une autre
place dans le processus que celui de l'
expertise de lagence troisièmement il
faut que les opinions des experts
ce qui amène de la contradiction quand
elles sont divergentes soit rendue
publique
et quatrièmement il y à un moment où il
doit y avoir une décision de prise et
alors là naturellement cette décision
doit être prise par des gens qui sont
totalement indépendants de tout de tout
lien d'intérêt même s'ils en ont eues
dans le passé mais ce que je voudrais
essayer de faire comprendre c'est que ma
position elle n'est pas noire ou blanche
elle consiste à dire que nous ne pouvons
pas aller si loin dans l'exclusion de
certains experts pour des motifs
d'intérêt que nous nous privons riom
d'une expertise utile à la santé
publique voilà et je reconnais que cet
équilibre à trouver n'est pas si facile
que ça à trouver bronzier vous dites
monsieur le ministre qu'il faut
conserver le système mis en place en
l'améliorant et vous voulez impliquer
davantage les médecins sa faim connaître
leur avis etc
mais vous savez sans doute que dans nos
provinces on manque de médecins que les
généralistes passe douze heures par jour
au moins
leur cabinet comment voulez vous qu'il
puisse trouver le temps entre chaque
client par exemple de prendre des notes
et de deux comment voulez vous qu'ils
aient en plus le temps de vous
renseigner
voilà donc comment pouvez-vous c'est
pour une mission qui n'est pas
secondaire elle est essentielle 1 c'est
pas du facultatif
en réalité ils ont déjà cette obligation
si dans leur diagnostic
il considère qu'il ya empoisonnement par
un médicament ou simplement risques
d'empoisonnement par un médicament c'est
c'est leur devoir déontologique premier
ça passe avant la consultation pour le
rhume des foins qui attend dans la salle
d'attenté
donc cela étant je suis moi même est lui
plus petit canton rural du département
de la manche est ce que je ce que vous
dites je l'entends parfaitement et je le
vois c'est une des grosses difficultés
que nous avons et nos médecins
généralistes se trouvent déjà submergées
de formalités administratives
il s'agit pas de denfert des
bureaucrates relevant le moindre petit
indice il s'agit quand même simplement
que quand il ya quelque chose qui leur
paraît grave même si l'on doute il
s'agit pas qu'ils aient ya une certitude
absolue il le signale moi ce que je
reproche à notre façon de procéder c'est
que le médecin de brest dont j'oublie le
nom qui s'est battu pour le médiator il
n'a tout simple c'est un show madame
irène matage irène frachon n'a tout
simplement pas été écoutés alors ça
c'est quelque chose qui me paraît
absolument pas remis le diagnostic que
nous avons apportées sur notre système
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut écouter les
zozos mais quand vous avez quelqu'un qui
a relevé des choses objectives
vous devez normalement déclencher une
réaction pour réévaluer les choses ou
alors
c'est que vous considérez que celui d'un
médecin qui ne devrait pas exercer la
médecine parce qu'il n'est pas compétent
enfin je crois que là le rôle des
médecins est très important il est très
difficile mais au delà de la difficulté
qu'ils ont dans leur emploi du temps de
généralistes milliards a été générale
ici à l'hôpital
et puis il n'ya pas que les généralistes
du monde rural bon mais je crois que au
delà de ça il y à aussi notre
organisation est ce que l' agence
régionale de santé est équipé pour
accueillir les signalements des médecins
est-ce que je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
l'assurance maladie est équipé pour
évaluer l'adéquation des prescriptions
au diagnostic
la réponse dans les deux cas et non et
je pense que quand on pense réforme
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas si on veut
vraiment améliorer la sécurité sanitaire
porter l'effort uniquement sur les
institutions nationales chargées de la
mise sur le marché des médicaments
dossier pharmaceutique qui en matière
bien d'entendre piétin à dossiers un par
un relais important et qui permet de on
a auditionné ici présidente du conseil
une mobilisation immédiate pour
connaître en fait le volume d'un certain
nombre de prêts strict de prescription
encore faut-il qu'il y ait une relation
étroite avec l'assurance maladie
je comprends pourquoi vous ne parlez pas
du dossier médical personnel
mais parce que c'est un serpent mer
n'ont peut-être depuis 2005 on nous le
promet nous sommes en 2011 et nous avons
toujours rien vu venir
mais oui peut-être une mémoire trop
lointaine et c'était déjà dans la
réforme de la jupe et donc c'est pire
que ce que vous dites oui il en va
disons qu elle a été matérialisée
concrétiser
vous en souvenez sans doute monsieur
tous le plaisir à l'époque vous avez dit
serré nous permettent de réaliser une
économie de 3 milliards d'euros et que
vous prévoyez on prévoit les la mise en
oeuvre de ce dmp pour 2007 et je suis
heureux et fier que ça n'ait pas été le
cas si je regrette oui bien sûr nous
avons au moins ça en commun les
personnes comme le carnet de santé des
enfants et personne à l'époque n'a voulu
de cet outil qui était matérialisé de
cette façon là ç'aurait été une première
on l'a tous classés mais est on l'a tous
reçu madame blandin merci c'est le
président monsieur le ministre vous avez
en partie déjà ouvert la porte en
signalant votre volonté que soit entendu
les les alertes vous présidez
aujourd'hui une agence résultant d'une
fusion de deux organismes de culture
radicalement opposées l'afssaps que
entre nous je qualifie la fsa que je
qualifierais de complaisante et deux
autistes par rapport aux alertes
je vais signalé le bisphénol et l'afsset
qui avait acquis une culture des
couteaux point de mettre dans son
conseil d'administration des
représentants de différentes
associations servant de relais aux
donneurs d' alerte et le choix a été
fait que dans le conseil
d'administration de l'ansès on reprenne
ses représentants et je m'en félicite
ne pourrait-on imaginer justement pour
l'afssaps à dispositif dans le conseil
d'administration de représentants de de
cette écoute d'honneur alerte un autre
schéma a été envisagée il a été voté
dans le grenelle une
auto le principe d'une haute autorité de
l'expertisé indépendant de
l'indépendance de l'expertisé et de
l'ecoute des lanceurs d'alert sa forme
n'a pas été définie on a dit une
instance ça peut être une autorité ça
peut être une inspection permanente mais
l'idée c'est d'être la garante par
sondage un peu comme la chambre des
comptes que les protocoles les
déclarations d'intérêts la publication
des avis contradictoires et cetera soit
réel dans tous les organismes
ce regard extérieur sur les agences en
plus du travail que fait l'agencé al
interne vous semble-t-il intéressant
merci madame la sénatrice je reviendrai
pas sur vos appréciations sur les
cultures différentes
elles se sont en tout cas est rejointe
au sein de la nouvelle on cesse et c'est
vrai que une des raisons qui m'ont fait
accepter de présider le conseil
d'administration de cette agence c'est
l'intérêt que je trouve à l'institution
d'un conseil d'administration qui
comporte cinq collèges et bien sûr celui
de l'état dont je précise que même si en
nombre de personne ni les minoritaires
il détient la majorité des voix ce qui
est normal puisque le conseil
d'administration essentiellement prendre
des décisions d'andreu budgétaire et que
le lagence fonctionne avec des
subventions de l'état
mais les autorités de tutelle s'exprime
sous le regard et avec la participation
par leurs délibérations et par leur vote
de quatre autres collèges
nous avons les représentants des
collectivités territoriales
nous avons les organisations non
gouvernementales associations de défense
des consommateurs associations de
défense de l'environnement
nous avons les parties prenantes du
monde économique dont la légitimité
n'est pas récuser industries agricoles
et alimentaires agriculture industrielle
et puis
et nous avons naturellement les
représentants du personnel qui sont
présents au conseil d'administration ça
fait un conseil d'administration très
tonique où se développe une culture du
primat de la sécurité sanitaire qui est
l'intérêt de tous on a bien vu dans la
crise de la vache folle à quel point
l'agriculture était tributaire pour ses
débouchés de la qualité sanitaire des
aliments et par conséquent chacun forge
une culture du primat de la sécurité
sanitaire à l'intérieur de ces conseils
d'administration je précise mais vous
n'avez certainement pas voulu dire le
contraire l'expression lanceur d'alert
pose question pour moi car une des
choses auxquelles je vais depuis ces
quelques semaines que je préside le
conseil d'administration c'est à ne pas
mélanger les rôles
le conseil d'administration est garant
des moyens de l'indépendance
scientifique de la vence
il adopte aussi le programme de travail
de lagence mais il n'a aucune
qualification en matière d expertise par
conséquent lanceur d'alert je veux bien
ça veut dire quoi
pour moi ça veut dire que les
institutions organismes associations
représentées au conseil d'administration
ne sont pas qualifiés pour dire si oui
ou non un produit est dangereux les
expertises c'est pas elle qui la
détiennent mais ils peuvent dire j'ai de
l'inquiétude sur ce sujet je constate
que l' agence la famille en oeuvre une
étude permettant d'y voir plus clair et
je demande que ce soit le cas ça je le
mets au vote du conseil d'administration
et je demande à la direction générale de
lancer quelque chose
nous venons d'adopter d'ailleurs le
programme de travail il a été débattu au
conseil d'administration et nous avons
entendu les uns et les autres
d'ailleurs il avait été préparée dans
des commissions ou des représentants des
différentes organismes associations etc
du conseil d'administration siéger et
donc lanceur d'alert oui à condition de
ne pas mélanger
expertise et préoccupations de sécurité
sanitaire dans un domaine donné
oui madame ben jeu mais je voulais poser
un deux questions à monsieur le ministre
alors une première
nous avons auditionné monsieur hirsch
qui est donc un ancien directeur de
l'afssa qui s'impliquent encore lens s
et qui a dans cette déclaration qui nous
a fait indirectement porter une
accusation à l'encontre de l'ancien si
j'aimerais bien que vous y répondiez
voilà ce qui vous a déclaré l'agent ce
que j'ai dirigé il ya quelques années a
récemment publié un rapport sur les
régimes amaigrissants
il n'y a pas eu un mot sur les pilules
amaigrissantes
or le président de ce comité d'experts
est payé par les quatre plus gros
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
même s'il est honnête comment voulez
vous qu'ils dénigrent ses employeurs il
ne peut y avoir de bonnes déontologie si
les conflits d'intérêts ne sont pas des
loups et qu'il s'agisse de conflits
individuels ou institutionnels
qu'avez vous à répondre à cette
observation que nous en fait monsieur
hirsch lors de son audition le président
je suppose que si vous a fait cette
déclaration c'est que il est sûr de son
en informations en ce qui me concerne
vous n'étiez pas je ne suis pas informé
je n'ai pas été informé de ce 6 mai en
tout état de cause je vous signale même
si ça n'est pas une excuse que qui dit
régime amaigrissant ne dit pas
traitement amaigrissant
et s'il vous plaît quand même où notre
agence c'est un peu ce messieurs
li fier pour évaluer les effets des
médicaments il y en a une autre dont
vous parlez beaucoup dansé la charge et
donc par conséquent cette question est
en réalité très importante
l'agencé de sécurité des aliments ne
peut se prononcer que sur des aliments
'cela va de soi je pense que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça oui m'enfin bon mais ni
n'y a pas de lien matériel entre une
pilule et des épinards et par conséquent
nous le prononçant sur la qualité des
épinards et pas sur la qualité des
pilules ne mets pas ça mais si je veux
bien le savoir je souhaite vivement
vivement que l' agence des produits de
santé fasse pleinement son métier qu'est
ce que mes quelques 200 de plus que la
confusion que peut-être je ne crois pas
que la confusion des missions en entre
agences fasse progresser la sécurité
sanitaire et vous non plus ou alors vous
faites une très grande agence ou vous
mettez à la fois les médicaments les
autres produits de santé les aliments
les produits que ce qui avait été
envisagé initialement soutenu vous en
tout tout peut se discuter moi je n'ai
pas de religion dans ce dans ce domaine
bien dernier à christophe a dernièrement
ce qui concerne la question est qui
concerne la le financement de la
formation médicale continue enfin on
appelle ça maintenant le développement
professionnel continu
en attendant d'ailleurs que que ça
change et 7
et lorsque il ya quelques années j'avais
essayé de traduire dans les faits les
propositions du rapport restaurer la
confiance que le sénat avait élaboré en
2006 s'est jetée pose est donc
régulièrement des amendements et j'avais
donc déposé alors que vous étiez je
pense ce ministre de la santé un
amendement concernant l'interdiction
pour les laboratoires de participer un
as au financement de l'information et
qu'il continue vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
l'élaborateur participe à peu près à 90
pour 98% à ce financement alors je passe
le débat mais vous m'aviez répondu la
participation de l'industrie
pharmaceutique à l'information des
prescripteurs est indispensable et pas
seulement pour des raisons financières
alors je voudrais savoir si vous avez
toujours la même opinion ou si vous avez
évolué sur ce point est ce que vous
pourriez lire l'ensemble de ma réponse
s'il vous plaît monsieur pas dire que je
m'en souvienne bien parce que je vois ce
passage est mais j'ai vu qu'il soit est
inscrit dans son contexte
écoutez le contexte jamais donc déposé
un amendement qui supprimait un article
du code de la santé publique
je le compléter en interdisant en
autorisant par l'industrie
pharmaceutique de financer des actions
de formation médicale continue et le
rapporteur avait donc émis un avis
défavorable à cet amendement
et vous aviez indiqué que le
gouvernement partageons tous points la
vie que monsieur le rapporteur vient
d'exprimer monsieur le sénateur vous
avez déploré tout à l'heure le fait que
nous n'ayons pas demandé de retirer
votre amendement laisse entendre que
vous l'auriez fait si nous vous l'avions
demandé au vu des explications qui
viennent de vous êtes à porter nous vous
demandons donc instamment de bien
vouloir retirer l'amendement numéro
treize numéros de 113 dont je n'avais
pas ce que ça danse ça me paraissait pas
très intéressant enfin puisque et vous
dites
en effet la participation de l'industrie
pharmaceutique à la formation des
prescripteurs est indispensable et pas
seulement pour des raisons financières
nous avons d'ailleurs eu tout à l'heure
un débat sur les modalités de
progression de la recherche et du
développement de nouveaux médicaments et
monsieur bernard murat disait exactement
et vous avez continué pour que ces
médicaments
je sais pas si ça représente un intérêt
de lire la suite ça vous suffit
non je suis très heureux de l'entendre
mais président mais si j'ai bien compris
vous vous référez vous que vous je suis
méchant qui à travers moi je suis référé
à ce que disait le rapporteur et je ne
vais pas vous demander de nous le
rappeler
alors alors je crois que je m'abstiens
de vous le demandez pas ce que je
voudrais pas que vous vous sentiez
obligé de 2,2 de lire de longs discours
fastidieux mais si vous voulez je vous
en prie et voilà alors monsieur le
rapporteur dit en voilà une bonne idée
entre parenthèses sourire je suis
surpris que le gouvernement n'y ai pas
pensé plus tôt
c'est à dire ont fui à la suppression du
financement voilà la solution qui permet
de diminuer d'autant l'impact de la taxe
de 20 96 % sur le chiffre d'affaires
ainsi on ferait faire aux laboratoires
une économie de 1 1% sur leur chiffre
d'affaires mais pourquoi n'y avons-nous
pas pensé plus tôt monsieur le ministre
monsieur autun veut rendre service aux
laboratoires mais comment allons-nous
dorénavant financer la formation
médicale continue pour l'instant ce sont
les laboratoires qui contribuent à ce
financement que proposez vous monsieur
autun plus sérieusement dans le cadre de
la réforme de l'assurance maladie
nous avons prévu une charte de la visite
médicale je ne sais pas où on en est
mais elle a fait l'objet de discussions
et de négociations avec les laboratoires
et doit entrer en application elle
devrait donc bientôt porter ses fruits
grâce à la mise en oeuvre de cette
charte dispositions que vous n'avez
d'ailleurs pas voter lors de l'examen du
projet de loi relatif à l'assurance
maladie
j'ai répondu je n'en suis pas sûr parce
que je crois l'avoir au thème enfin peu
importe leur ion atteindre l'objectif
que vous poursuivez monsieur le sénateur
vous empruntez donc une autre voie pour
aboutir au même résultat
conscient que cette sharp répondre à vos
attentes nous estimons que votre
amendement est satisfait aussi je vous
demande de bien vouloir leur tirer à
défaut la commission émettra un avis
evra je pense que là on a vraiment
tout le contexte maintenant vous la met
à disposition je vous remercie pouvoir
une fastidieuse pour cette excuse est
due à la demande de monsieur le
président ancien ministe merci mais si
vous lui demandez à cette question de
contexte et je vous remercie d'avoir
préciser les choses
alors comme vous l'avez rappelé le rôle
de l'industrie pharmaceutique en matière
de formation continue est très important
et je comprends que à l'époque même si
je ne m'en souvenais pas votre
amendement et été rejetée avec un avis
défavorable du gouvernement que j'ai
donné moi même pour une raison très
simple c'est que s'il s'agit de passer
d'un système à l'autre
il ne suffit pas d'abolir le système
ancien encore faut-il mettre en place le
système nouveau en même temps et l'avoir
concertée alors je ne crois pas en effet
qu'il soit absolument indispensable
d'interdire toute participation de
l'industrie pharmaceutique à la
formation médicale continue vous avez un
nouveau médicament contre une maladie
très grave qui a été mise au point par
un industriel un laboratoire
pharmaceutique avec toutes les garanties
il a piloté des essais cliniques
il le présente aux médecins c'est de la
formation médicale continue et cette
formation est nécessaire pour
l'information du prescripteur
ce qui est important c'est que cette
information soit une information de
qualité et c'est à dire une information
médicale qui engage la responsabilité de
chacun des médecins qui participent
là encore
le système mérite d'être réformé
améliorée il doit l'être je crois sans
exclure absolument toute participation
du laboratoire de ces pharmaciens des
médecins qui ont procédé aux essais
thérapeutiques à la diffusion du savoir
qui s'est développée dans un cadre
industriel dans l'intérêt de la santé
publique
je ne pars pas du principe que tout
laboratoire pharmaceutique a des
intentions criminelles ou des attentions
économique qui absorbe la totalité des
motivations de ceux qui travaillent pour
la mise au point des médicaments
je vous rappelle quand même monsieur le
ministre que une directive européenne
considère qu' une information qui émane
d'une entreprise n'est pas une
information de la publicité c'est pas
moi qui le dit c'est une je pourrais
vous faire part ni dan d'ailleurs les
extraits de cette directive européenne
écoutez je vous la ferez parvenir sans
tarder on remercie rapporteur de nous
avoir donné un certain nombre de
suggestions parce que nous avons une
mission bien évidemment de contrôle mais
d'impulsion aussi d'une politique et il
est important aussi
à travers ce que nous allons dire
d'essayer aussi de restaurer la
confiance vis-à-vis du médicament et de
prendre aussi la mesure de ce que l'
expertise nous donne aujourd'hui une pas
discréditée systématiquement les
expertises avant que vous quittiez je
voudrais
poser une question est ce que vous
pensez qu'il y à des problématiques
sanitaires qui aurait pu qui pourrait au
kippour en main être tus pour des
raisons économiques pour des raisons
financières ou pour des raisons ou pour
des raisons idéologiques
par exemple on sait que parce que je
connais la personne à qui c'est arrivé
et elle est elle même médecin
une personne est décédée suite au 1 rue
486 et personne n'en a parlé parce que
c'est toute une politique de santé
publique qui est qui est impulsée et on
dit dans la ferme du médiator fût ce un
patient décédé
il est important de le mettre en exergue
moi j'ai l'impression quelques fois
qu'il ya des champs sanitaire ou qui
relève de l'alimentation parce qu'ils
induisent telle politique effectivement
quand on parle d'obésité ça induit tout
un marché d'alimentation pour des
produits allégés ou bien quand on donne
telle orientation comme politique
sanitaire vis-à-vis de la femme est ce
que vous pensez j'ai découvert récemment
ce qu'on appelle les produits
thérapeutiques innovants pour tout ce
qui concerne tout ce qui est autre
auxiliaire pour les gels de tout ce
qu'il y ait des condamnations in vitro
dont il n'y a aucun contrôle semble-t-il
aujourd'hui est ce que vous pensez qu'il
y à certaines problématiques qui par
omission
ne sont pas mises en exergue et que
demain à la fin d'une autre conclusion
finalement sur le médiator une autre
affaire pourrait surgir et alors est ce
que le sénat l'assemblée nationale d'eau
à nouveau se constituer en commission
d'information voilà masse le sujet je
vais faire une réponse de principe
d'abord je pense que aussi difficile
soit elle
toute décision en matière de sécurité
sanitaire doit être précédée de
l'information la plus complète sur les
paramètres de la décision la plus
complète la plus objective la plus
contradictoires s'il y a des
contradictions n'est pas toujours le cas
d'ailleurs de sorte que l'on puisse
justifier cette décision aux yeux des
français
je suis très sensible au fait qu' il est
toujours plus facile d'inquiéter que de
rassurer la mission d'une agence née de
faire ni l'un ni l'autre
elle est de dire la vérité et c'est en
disant la vérité que l'on peut même s'il
ya risque justifier les décisions qui
sont prises qui ne doivent pas
d'ailleurs toute concession consisté à
faire semblant de croire que le risque
zéro est atteignable et que toute
décision de sécurité sanitaire doit
nécessairement aller aux extrêmes si
j'ose dire
nous disions tout à l'heure très je
crois que tout le monde est d'accord là
dessus il n'existe pas de médicament qui
ne comporte pas de contre indications
par exemple
tout est dans le bon usage du médicament
est donc dans le bon usage il ya
naturellement la dose et le respect de
cette dose et le suivi du traitement et
donc ce sont des questions infiniment
complexe je ne voudrais pas
effectivement qu'on arrive à des
situations où sous le coup de l'émotion
on retirerait un médicament parce qu'il
a donné lieu à un ou plusieurs
6dans alors même qu'en retirant ce
médicament on priverait des milliers ou
des dizaines de milliers de patients
d'un traitement qui leur est
indispensable et par conséquent il ya
toujours une balance à faire entre un
risque qui existe est un avantage pour
les malades qui peut être vital alors
même que le risque aussi pourrait être
vital est donc en ce qui me concerne je
crois à la nécessité d'une explication
d'autant plus forte que si cette
explication n'a pas lieu
nous serons tous emportés par la vague
de tsunami de l'émotion à chaque fois
qu'une émotion qu'une quelqu'un
événement sanitaires plus ou moins
graves plus ou moins circonscrit aura
lieu alors vous citer des exemples que
je ne connais pas et qui ne se
rattachent pas exactement à ma réponse
me semble-t-il puisque en réalité ce que
vous voulez nous dire c'est qu'il y à
des sujets pour lequel il y a en quelque
sorte un couvercle qui est mis pour que
l'information ne se diffuse pas car des
forces en présence ne veulent surtout
pas qu'elle se diffuse
si elles sont susceptibles de remettre
en cause des pratiques que ces forces
défendent et il y a derrière ceux ci une
forme d'obscurantisme
moi je crois qu'il est très important de
toujours distingué le la conviction
qu'on peut avoir sur l'utilisation d'un
produit utile que ce soit pour la santé
ou pour des raisons qui ne sont pas
réellement de santé mais de moeurs et
les risques sanitaires qu'il fait
encourir très bien dire que on est pas
hostile au développement de telles
pratiques que pour autant on met en
garde contre certains risques auxquels
cette pratique peut exposer la chape de
plomb n'est jamais la bonne
solution et je pense qu'il faut vraiment
mettre les choses sur la table avec
maîtrise et en argumentant estime à
propos de l'argumentation
je parle pas brutaliser mais est on est
à 42
bon certes on a commencé en retard par
ma faute mais nous avons encore alors si
plus personne ne voulait intervenir je
pense que hélas le devrions terminer
même si il reste encore beaucoup de
questions a évoqué un éventuel mans où
vous auditionneront une autre fois donc
il me reste à vous remercier pour ce que
vous nous avez indiqué ce matin
merci merci fils
c'est la fin de cette audition consacrée
au scandale du médiator pour la revoir
notre site internet publicsenat.fr
prochain rendez-vous avec l'actualité
parlementaire cet après midi 15 heures
bonne journée à tous sur public sénat